kyle brandt co-host of nfl network's
good morning football
and he's got a new podcast and uh his
first guest
with his podcast was aaron rodgers the
new podcast 10 questions with kyle brent
now available on spotify youtube
and uh aaron rodgers and they created
some headlines a couple of weeks ago
when some of the excerpts uh
leaked out or they had them leak out and
kyle joins us now on the program
congrats on the podcast there nice
get the first guest there kyle thanks
dan i'm thrilled to be here and uh
if you're starting a podcast you better
have a banger first track on that album
or somebody's going to the other one
it's tough out there in the podcast
streets a lot of traffic so rogers did
me a huge solid man
now sources close to me tell me that
aaron rodgers was drinking scotch
throughout
the two-hour interview on your podcast
is it mandatory that every guest will be
drinking to answer your questions
absolutely they have to sign something
that says not only will they drink and
they will drink heartily i did this on a
friday night
it was in the evening i mean this is
this is like eight or nine o'clock it's
just when he could do it
and he sits down and he's got a
massive glass of scotch and we talked
for almost two hours then
he pulled from the scotch throughout
up through high wire act questions
difficult topics you could almost play a
drinking game just drink every time
rogers drinks
and it's ironic because he's the one who
got his chops busted because he couldn't
chug a beer and everyone said ha ha you
can't chug a beer
this guy can put it back like daniel day
lewis and there will be blood it was
so much whiskey and still he was so
erudite and open it was a dream shot
what's the most honest or revealing
moment you had
well a couple in in a long talk there
was a couple
on the surface level damn i was shocked
to find out that uh
aaron rodgers is a massive karaoke guy
and his go-to song is an 80s power
ballad by the scorpions
called wind of change which is about
socioeconomic politics in the soviet
union
it's a heavy jam but he goes to that
routinely and apparently has karaoke
parties in green bay after games
okay now what was the revealing moment
that
like was there something because we know
what's happened in the offseason here
when he found out they were taking
jordan love yeah the
most revealing moment i think this
what's really was startling about it dan
was just
there was such certainty in the way he
spoke about the end of his times in
green bay
he knows for a fact that clear's day
that he won't
one day play an nfl game without a green
bay packers uniform because
he doesn't want to stop playing he wants
to play well into his 40s i'm talking
another five six
seven seasons and there was no
frustration
no anger almost a touch of sadness but
when you talk about
how's this thing going to end he just
says well they're going to go with the
kid they're going to go with jordan love
i know that for a fact
and there's it's not as if he spent the
summer wrestling with it after the pick
i think he just is so calm and i was
expecting some frustration especially as
the scotch kicked in but no it's just
calm certainty as if someone who knows
what their fate is and they're just
going to ride it out
he's kyle brandt co-host of nfl
network's good morning football
ten questions with kyle brandt his
podcast now available on spotify and
youtube
i wanted to bring this up and play it
for you play it for the audience
and it's a little bit lengthy but it has
to do with aaron rodgers
view his take on the media so this is
part of the podcast
what would i you know laugh at do not
spend any time watching but
unfortunately you know it's usually like
espn's on here and
uh you know the network works on over
there kind of in our cafeteria it's just
like four guys
you know four men or four women or
whoever
it shakes out and everybody's just
trying to say the most
outlandish thing possible to get the
most clickbait and i've said it many
times about clickbait
my problem with with putting ridiculous
headlines on the story
this is that in this culture where the
attention span is so short for so many
people
even people probably listen to this
interview are watching us who you know
can't stay on
the entire time because they've got
other things to do when everything's
looking on their phone
you know it's like all they're gonna
read is eight words
on an espn front page and that and they
think that's gonna you know
that's what these people are trying
people to click on because they get a
one second page you know one second on
that page that counts as the page view
and the more pages you get the more ad
revenue you get and i think it's it's
really low class journalism it's like
some of the
headlines that get put on some of these
articles that have nothing to do with
what's
actually content-wise in an article i
think it's
i think it's poor journalism i think
it's a total lack of integrity
and i don't want to listen i don't want
to look at that i don't want to listen
to four people
on some show yell at each other about
opinions that do they really
feel that way is that like well they
just want to be the most outlandish
you know opinion possible so they get
the most views when it gets
you know retweeted on twitter or posted
on a 10 second blurb on espn.com or
something i just think it's
i think it's really done a disservice to
the uh
you know to the uh industry of
journalism for sure
so what'd you make of that it's very
surprised
the question was just hey aaron you
watched a lot of football tv what's your
least favorite kind what's the little
pet peeve you had
and i thought he was going to go to x's
and o's because i know he's spoken
before about
analysts doing x's and o's drives him
crazy because they always have it wrong
and we'd have some laughs but um he took
a deep breath
he kind of loosened his neck up and then
he let it rip
and it goes on and on and we talk about
um some of the debate shows and espn
shows and i mentioned steven a by name
and there's an inference of the bayless
types and whatnot and he uses words like
sellout
and he uses words like integrity and he
was really
really really pissed about that whole
thing and i was surprised by it
but i think there's a lot of scar tissue
there that seemed to me like one of
these things just let it all out
after years and years and years there's
a couple other things dan if you pay
attention to him really closely i know
you've spoken to him a bunch
i i don't i can't put words in his mouth
but there seems to be some problem with
espn as a whole
there's another part in our conversation
where he was talking about the summer of
2008 which was a huge summer for him
because it was the far vacillating
between retiring and is it going to be
aaron or not
and he said he was in tahoe playing on
the golf tournament he just as a
throwaway comment he says you know i did
the sunday conversation because they
tricked me into that
and i followed on it and he kind of
didn't want to get into it anymore but
there seems to be an espn issue again i
can't speak for him but
uh in two hours of talking i think it
was this most passionate
vein in the neck bulging type rant and i
think there's more where that came from
uh just so you know full disclosure i
verbally spanked you a couple of weeks
ago when you
sent out a tweet about people in the
industry
maybe rooting against the football
season so
i wanted to i wanted to give you that
opportunity to
um maybe clarify or maybe it was
semantics
or maybe you didn't understand that how
people were going to take that but
you kind of said i'm i'm uh not quoting
verbatim but
there are people in the industry who are
rooting against the football season to
start
right or and i told you so
yeah i i think it was uh it almost feels
like certain people in the football
industry are rooting for the
the season to be affected yeah and you
know i've been asked
do i regret tweeting that and dan for
people who
you were listening who don't know me i'm
not a provocateur
i don't lob grenades on twitter i don't
say things i don't incite
it's just not how i make my living so
sure i regret it just because there were
some people were really insulted by it
and there are people who i respect and
even more importantly people that i like
that were insulted by it it sounds like
maybe i'm talking to one
but at the same time the reason why the
tweet resonated and the reason why it's
interesting isn't just because i
made a stupid tweet and pissed people
off it's because in addition to all the
people who were mad about it there were
thousands and thousands and thousands of
likes
it seemed to tap into something that
people also felt which was very strange
and i'll tell you this
then if i could go back i wouldn't tweet
it because i'm not in the business of
just pissing people off but i also
didn't take it down
because i do think that there's a thread
of truth to what i tweeted
yeah and look it didn't ruin my day i
just you know my
my point is that it makes my job easier
when there is the nfl it makes my job
easier people accuse me on monday when i
had the story
college football is closing up shop in
the big ten in pac-12 people said
oh you're getting your wish i my job has
been so much tougher the last four
months
i now we have sports i i would i
can't imagine not having football in the
fall certainly with the nfl so
it didn't ruin my day i just i felt bad
for you because i
i understood what you were saying i just
don't know if you knew how people are
going to consume it
in the industry i think you're probably
right and listen
i make my living off football every
morning too i've taken a pay cut already
i may take another and of course you
know dan the columnist and the radio
host and
the nfl lifer of course they're not
rooting for the season to be affected at
all
but it was the end of the show it was a
long show it was a tedious show and the
miami marlins news started coming down
and i just got kind of depressed i
didn't like it i felt bad i felt down on
myself
and you go to twitter which is the worst
decision possible and
i got pissed off by some of the tone
that i was reading it's just
listen all you me of course we're
waiting for this season
i think though there is a small yet
pungent minority who are rooting for the
nfl to be humbled
yeah and i think that's what i was
responding to yes and i think that uh
you know we've heard that with baseball
anytime i bring news that's negative
news
i get people who say oh you might be
getting your wish like and
like i'm not i know i i'm my wish
is that we have sports you know that's
all
um like you're blaming the pizza guy the
delivery guy if the pizza is bad
i didn't make it i'm just delivering it
to you uh sources close to me tell me
that you have a couple of questions
for me you're gonna turn the tables kyle
is that what you're gonna do all right
well dan this is my channel paulie you
got some scotch you already had some
oh i got some tequila
all right so the deal is dan with with
the new show i had to do something
different i can't just sit down and have
a guest on and ask a couple questions i
don't have the platform or maybe the
talent
so i asked rogers and i've asked aaron
paul rudd and tyron matthew and kirk
cousins you asked them a trivia question
could be totally random
if they get it they get a point if they
don't they get nothing and then we
reveal how it's attached to their life
so would you be willing to indulge in
two questions sure you're in sure why
not
all right here we go dan patrick
question number one your category
is breakfast dan what
sugary breakfast cereal is infamous
for cutting the roof of your mouth when
you eat it
captain crunch always did that for me
captain crutches writes dan patrick that
is right
it is captain crunch navy man and the
reason i'm asking you about captain
captain crunch
dan is that you have a history with a
different captain
a very infamous one by the name of
captain jenks yes
and you and i have joked about this off
the air but i never got
to ask you about it you were
interviewing a farcical steve bartmann
on sportscenter when howard stern
prankster captain jenks got you on live
tv
incredible moment when you look back on
that dan do you shake your head or do
you laugh
i laugh because there was nothing
i i mean i i love captain jenks and
howard stern
so part of me is like damn i'm going to
be on howard stern show
but the other part of me is holy bleep
i'm i'm
live on sportscenter and i just got i
got humbled i
i won an fme by uh howard and robin
so part of me was very proud that i
screwed up to get on howard's show
the other part was i'm live on
sportscenter and that's not steve
bartman i'm talking to
dan i i say this with due respect i've
watched you for decades it's one of my
favorite moments of your broadcasting
career
because the reaction when he says do you
like howard stern's bleep cheese
yeah you take a deep breath you look
down
and then you look at the camera and say
we've been had yeah
and then listen up coming up we'll play
factor fiction and warren sapp has gone
from hunter to the hunted
more sports center after this the
recovery was incredible
oh i'm sweating as we speak with you
retelling that uh any other questions so
you're one for one okay yes so question
number two okay let's see if we can stay
hot dan patrick no help from the nx
please okay your category
is cinema what actress
was nominated for an academy award
for her role in the film casino
sharon stone
patrick's on fire
yeah i'm as hot as the fake fireplace
behind you there kyle
that started that fireplace it almost
almost looked real
it almost looks real it's it's the fire
from my
takes dan you know that's what you got
oh yeah yeah you said sherry stone the
connective tissue to you there
uh stone i also think of stone cold
steve austin one of my favorite sports
center commercials when you hit him with
a wheelchair
what are your memories of hitting stone
cold with a chair
well he told me to do it harder and he
put this little pad
on the middle of his back and he had had
back issues
and so the whole premise was he's there
studying in our
break room i come in i'm doing late
night sports center
and he's like he's gotta stretch a
little bit and then he goes can you help
me here dan
and i grab this metal chair that i still
have it's in the studio somewhere
and i hit him and the paper on the wall
uh bulletin board was like and he goes
you got to make it real you got to hit
me harder and i go okay
after the fourth time i was like all
right i'm bringing all the cheese i got
and i hit him so damn hard
and he didn't budge and he just thanked
me that i
hit this little pad on his back because
i couldn't imagine if i missed
i would have broke something on him
the last one you crow hopped and did a
full uh
throw from the warning track dan my last
follow-up is
when it came to the sports center
commercials and the casting
did it get really competitive amongst
anchors and were their feelings hurt
yeah there were people who didn't want
to be part of it i remember bob lee
and some other anchors they were above
it
i i will say that if there was a
commercial shoot a promo shoot stuart
scott would have been first in line
to be there no matter what stewart was
always if you needed a sports center
anchor
stuart scott was there we did have
people who were lobbying
for certain commercials with certain
sports stars
um and then we had like gordy howell was
going to be with oberman
uh lance armstrong was going to be with
me they you know some athletes ask for
certain anchors to be
in their promos but competitive yeah a
little bit
uh but you know what that changed
sportscenter it uh that that
ad campaign was one of the great ones in
history but
um i've got to go i can't just sit here
it's not a two-hour podcast
where i can just drink scotch but um
congratulations on it's great to talk to
you and give my best to uh
good morning america good morning
football america good morning
america football i will do that dan you
can spank me anytime
that's kyle kyle brandt he's the popular
co-host of
nfl network's good morning football and
uh ten questions with kyle brand now
available on spotify on youtube